Would you recommend testosterone therapy for recovering cancer patients in 72 and doing well post bladder cancer operation one year, but my energy level has never returned.
I have her testosterone can be having accelerated effect on cancer cells.
So I, you know, a lot of times when people ask about testosterone therapy, they're actually talking about energy deprivation therapy with with a prostate cancer.
But that's not very sure this is what you're asking. You're asking about testosterone replacement therapy, which would be bioidentical horrible replacement therapy, you see testosterone.
Is that bad to do for cancer patients or male cancer patients with bladder cancer, I would say, no, it's, I wouldn't say it's bad to you.
So I would recommend so I pull it up here real quick.
There's a product that we have just started carried private label product called stamina.
It is marketed outside of our private label that's marketed as a product to increase testosterone levels.
And it's, it's because of what the ingredients are. So it has this long a folia extract this from coma long a folia extract, which is shown to increase testosterone levels.
But the reason why we private label that is stamina is that that ingredient is not just for increasing testosterone levels. It's for basically increasing exactly what we called it stamina in males and females, not just males.
So it doesn't basically increase testosterone. It gives you that same type of boost. Don't it also has she and she is in it as well, which is so good for not, not just, it's so good for balancing hormones. It's really an adaptogen is what it is.
Plus it is also a healator. It's just a great product. I personally started taking this product that I was so happy with it that I thought we got a private label this now we haven't done any haven't done any videos on under blog post on it or anything yet.
So we just got this in, but I would as opposed to going with a testosterone bio identical hormone replacement. I would use this product because it has so many other benefits. There's data out there by taking taking chili with by itself. It's got 500 milligrams of that it it.
For two capsules of the product, there's there's data that that is amazing on that product. So I would use this in and not do testosterone replacement.
Personally, I am trained in bio identical hormone replacement. That was part of my functional medicine training through a for a years ago.
But never did it partly because of my licensure issues. I can't legally do that. But I never wanted to do it because even though that was the center of center point of my trading.
There's such a small percentage of people that I think that would benefit from that compared to that it could hurt them if they did have a unknown cancer.
So in that sense, the truth is just because, okay, in one sense, okay, I don't have prostate cancer. I had bladder cancer. Well, there's no telling that a person may have a small secondary prostate cancer.
His cancer growing, increasing testosterone levels with that be harmful. It could be in another sense, is there any farm and doing bio identical hormone therapy when you don't have any formal related cancer.
I'm not completely against it. It's just having that balance. You know, I understand the person
does have major issues, especially female. It's having major issues trying to get their hormones
balanced. If you're using progesterone or using estrogen or using testosterone can be
extremely helpful. So I'm not saying there's not cases that could be greatly benefited from it.
But I don't know. I would try a product like this before that.